alright who's this guy this is Mark
schlep mark looks scared yeah yeah boys
I got a debate club for you today we got
a barbecue a couple meals a couple dad
Drock in the Nike monarchs yeah then
they posed the question to you
hamburgers or hot dogs question of a
century Theo I feel like you've
definitely eaten some dirty burgers from
the trailer park on this let me know
Gang Gang bon bon peace that guy's a
champ yeah I mean estranged meats you
know I've eaten some meats that are
estranged from their family for sure
i'ma go hot dog do it I like cuz on a
hot dog you can see the burn marks a
little bit better you can see what it's
been through you know you can see the
tough times you can see the you know
they'll have a scar someplace where they
had little handcuffs on it or whatever
so I like that kind of thing more than a
burger you can't really see the you know
what it's been through that much yeah I
know what the [ __ ] you talking about
nice hunter percent beef burger I put
some [ __ ] deep a hot dog yard listen
I've had some times where I was in the
parking lot smoking crack and you know
smell hot dogs remind me of my mom
there's the thing about my mother one
time we had a kid named hot dogs mana
ray he liked to hit his head against the
wall man dude I like my burgers
disgusting disgusting I'm gonna Duke the
head of KKK like hot dog we be grilling
using some racist things and whatever
man nothing more American than hot dogs
he's changed okay what does this guy
want to know when grilling out burgers
or hot dogs for you boys I go I dog man
these days I don't do it often but in
the summer I go I'll throw a little
[ __ ] Wiener man [ __ ] of wiener listen
dude if I'm gonna need a dog to me a
bright you feel me a cheddar brought
with a nice thick bun I like that like
that oh yeah I've just heard all the
episodes about Justin Poirier we go way
back that double here around I heard you
mention since he lost told me not to
mention him
he's a champ bro
no he's not but I love them I'm a
hamburger guy bottom line bro yeah
brother okay 86% burgers all day that's
America but oh it's a food we from the
rocky and grill burgers bro know where
the [ __ ] you're from one eye of the
tiger and I won a damn [ __ ] be Frank
daddy okay fifty percent beef dude maybe
huh yeah you never know with hot dogs do
you you guys see 100% I really don't do
the math about 60 about 16 I think slimy
is [ __ ] yes also the do you guys have
the kids growing up being in Frank's
they'd have beans with cut up yeah what
kind of hot yeah lean and [ __ ] bro
then Wayne and [ __ ] like the pig in
the blanket ha ha he's some kind of dang
gonna blanket bro you guys know what
that is it's a little bit homoerotic
it's like a it's a it's a tank Frank
wrapped in like a croissant topic get me
out man starts making up more guys he
mad
[Music]
nothing
[Music]